Uber out with a big announcement they
are expanding the number of electric
vehicles on the platform all in effort
to cut pollution today the company is
launching a so-called Comfort electric
product it's going to be in 15 new
cities and states bringing the total
program rollout to 25 cities and states
all across North America you see them on
your screen now now in an exclusive
interview with Uber's CEO senior
National and environmental correspondent
Ben Tracy got an inside look at the
company's plan to cut those Planet
warming emissions
this is making me realize that this car
must be really fun in this city you
cannot beat this view look at that this
is awesome
absolutely spectacular very nice it's
hard to compete with this kind of
scenery in San Francisco but Uber CEO
Dara koshoshahi hopes Riders will also
appreciate the view inside the car one
of 26 000 electric vehicles now on
Uber's platform so it turned out to be a
great inspiration both for Riders but
especially drivers to go out and go
electric Uber has quadrupled its EV
Fleet in the U.S Canada and Europe in
the past year and plans to double it to
50 000 Vehicles next year all part of
its new product called Comfort electric
it's a Tesla a pole star a Ford Maki
these are great cars what is kind of the
end goal of putting so many more EVS on
your platform by 2030 we have a Target
to be fully electric in the U.S Canada
and Europe by 2030 will a driver who is
driving a gas-powered vehicle be allowed
on your platform uh no if we're doing
our job we're going to be all electric
in the U.S transportation is the single
largest source of Planet warming
greenhouse gas emissions
beautiful we have the Uber logo I love
it Uber is trying to slash its carbon
footprint hello how's it going by
incentivizing its drivers to switch to
EVS
but cheap no they're not cheap we need
electric vehicles and that cost twenty
thirty thousand dollars versus fifty to
sixty thousand dollars Uber says it's
going to spend 800 million dollars to
offset some costs for its drivers it's
paying them an extra dollar for every EV
trip they make and providing discounts
on charging Uber is partnering with
Hertz where drivers can now rent Teslas
on a weekly or monthly basis no pressure
I know it's not every day you have the
CEO of uber in your vaccine so very true
we're told he has a good rating and he's
a good passenger Uber driver Melissa
gilgen has been renting this red Tesla
since March
now that she's avoiding the pain at the
pump in California she says she's making
200 more per week driving the Tesla I
don't know about you but 200 a week adds
up you know for me that's like in my
family that's like a you know week's
worth of groceries right there and she
says going electric has boosted tips
from her Riders oh they absolutely love
the Tesla they're so excited I get less
cancellations actually
they'll wait a little longer for me very
cool on the downside I will tell you I
have noticed that sometimes it takes a
bit of time to get one of these drivers
and the ride's more expensive the more
electric cars we have in a particular
Market the the more the waiting time
comes down and pricing can come down as
well Uber says its goal is to be the
cleanest and safest Transportation
platform on the planet but its latest
safety report shows that in 2020 the
company received reports of 141 rapes
and 998 incidents of sexual assault
between drivers and passengers and that
was during the height of covid lockdowns
when far fewer people were using Uber
99.9 of uber trips are completely safe
no incidents whatsoever but we want to
be held accountable which is why we were
the first company out there to publish a
comprehensive safety report the very
fact that you have to put out a report
though does seem to lend Credence to the
fact that problem here the fact that
these incidents are happening is a big
problem he says Uber is adding new
safety features including ride check
where if a car stops unexpectedly Uber
will contact the rider or driver to make
sure things are okay have you considered
allowing women in particular to select
the gender of their driver we've
definitely considered that and we have
tested that in some countries there are
significantly more male drivers than
women drivers so a woman would have to
wait a long time if she wanted
specifically a woman driver most of my
passengers have never been in a Tesla
Melissa gilgan is unique a female Uber
driver behind the wheel of an EV but the
boss in the back seat sees a future with
a lot more of both on the road because
if we want to get to zero emissions by
2030 there's a lot of work to do like
the momentum is great but most of the
work is ahead of us not behind us for
CBS mornings I'm Ben Tracy in San
Francisco
okay looked like a five-star ride to me
I want to know what Dara the CEO is a
writer rating is because mine is a 474
and it frustrates me that I'm not above
475. but I don't know what good is but
but I love that the drivers get to rank
you I like that I love that and I like
the point that they were making though
about electric cars because I've now
come around to my next car when I get
one is I think it should be electric you
can't you after you hear all the
information you can't help but think
what can I do and yeah and how can I do
it yeah now commit the fact that they're
doing that by 2030 to be all electric
that's the goal yeah the assault numbers
that were a little jarring yeah I never
understand because they're tracking you
they track you when you get the car they
track you when you're inside the car I'm
glad they're they're planning to address
that too nicely done Ben and always good
to see Dara